the main mast of a fishing boat is
supported by a sturdy rope that extends
from the top of the mast to the deck if
the mast is 20 feet tall and the rope
attaches to the deck 15 feet away from
the base of the mast
how long is the rope so let's let's draw
ourselves a boat and make sure we
understand what the deck and the mast
and all of that is
so let me draw a boat let's see a nice
color i'll start with yellow
so let's say that this is my boat
that is the deck of the boat and the
boat might look something like this
it's a sailing boat
so that is the deck of the boat this is
the water down here
that is
the water and then the mast is the thing
that holds up the sails let me draw
ourselves a mast
so the mast so let me draw the mast just
like this
that is my mast and they say if the mast
is 20 feet tall it is 20 feet tall so
this distance right here is 20
feet that distance right there that is
what is holding up the sail i could draw
it as a pole so it's a little bit
clearer even shaded in if we like
and then they say a rope attaches to the
deck 15 feet away from the base of the
mass so this is the base of the mast
this is the deck right here the rope
attaches 15 feet away from the base of
the mast so the rope might attach so if
this is the base of the mast we go 15
feet might be about that distance right
there let me mark that this distance
right there is 15
feet
and the rope attaches right here from
the top of the mast all the way to that
base so the rope goes like that
and then they ask us how long is the
rope so there's a few things you might
realize we're dealing with a triangle
here and it's not any triangle we're
assuming that the mast goes straight up
and that the
deck is straight left and right so this
is a right triangle this is a 90 degree
angle right here
this is a right triangle and we know
that if we know two sides of a right
triangle we can always figure out the
third side of the right triangle using
the pythagorean theorem
pythagorean
pythagorean theorem
and all that tells us is that the square
the sum of the squares of the shorter
sides of the triangle are going to be
equal to the square of the longer side
and that longer side is called the
hypotenuse
and use and in this game in all cases
the hypotenuse is the side opposite the
90 degree angle is always going to be
the longest side of our right triangle
so we need to figure out the hypotenuse
here we know the lengths of the two
shorter sides so we can see that if we
take 15 squared
15 squared that's one of the shorter
sides i'm squaring it and then add that
to the square of the other shorter side
to 20 feet squared and when i say the
shorter side i mean relative to the
hypotenuse the hypotenuse will always be
the longest side
that is going to be equal to
let's say the hypotenuse is in green
just so we get our color coding nice
that is going to be equal to
the rope squared or the length of the
rope so let's call this distance right
here r
r for rope let me do a little bit neater
than that r4 rope is the length of the
rope
so 15 squared plus 20 squared is going
to be equal to r squared and what's 15
squared it's 225
20 squared
is 400
20 squared is 400 and that's going to be
equal to r squared
now 225 plus 400 is 625
625 is equal to r squared and then we
can take the principal root of both
sides of this equation because we're
talking about distances we want the
positive square root so you take the
positive square root or the principal
root of both sides of this equation and
you are left with
r is equal to the square root of 625 you
could play with it a little bit if you
like but
if you've ever played with numbers
around 25 you'll see that this is 25
squared so this is so r is equal to the
square root of 625 which is
25. so this distance right here the
length of the rope is equal to 25
feet